hi so this channel is about ai safety
and ai alignment the core idea of ai
safety is often portrayed like this
you're a human you have some objective
that you want to achieve
so you create an ai system which is an
optimizer being an optimizer means that
it has an objective
and it chooses its actions to optimize
i.e maximize or minimize that objective
for example a chess ai might choose what
moves to make in order to maximize its
chances of winning the game
a maze-solving algorithm might choose a
route that minimizes the time taken to
exit the maze
often being an optimizer involves
modeling your environment
running searches over the space of
actions and planning ahead
but optimizers can also be simpler than
that like a machine learning system like
gradient descent
might choose how to adjust the weights
of a neural network in order to maximize
the network's performance at a
particular task
that's optimization too so you the human
your objective might be to cure cancer
so you put the objective in here cure
cancer and then the optimizer selects
actions that it expects to result in
good outcomes according to this
objective but part of the reason we have
a problem
is that this and this will almost
certainly end up not being the same
especially when the objectives refer to
the real world with all its complexity
ambiguity and uncertainty so we have
this alignment problem
which is how do we get the objective in
the system to match exactly with the
objective in our minds
for example perhaps the best you can do
at describing your objective
is some code which corresponds to
minimize the number of people who have
cancer that might look okay to a first
glance but
it's actually not the same as your real
objective since this one can be
optimized by for example reducing the
number of living people to zero
no people means no cancer this is
obviously a very silly example but it's
indicative of a real and serious problem
the human objective is really the
totality of human ethics and values
it's very complicated and it's not clear
even to us getting the machine's
objective to exactly
align with ours is extremely difficult
and it's a big problem because if the ai
system is trying to optimize an
objective that's different from ours if
it's misaligned even slightly
then the human and the ai system are in
conflict
they're trying to achieve two different
things in only one world
right now these misalignments happen all
the time and they aren't a huge problem
because current ai systems tend to be
fairly weak and fairly narrow
so we can spot the misalignments pretty
easily and modify the systems as much as
we want to fix them
but the more general and the more
capable the system is
the bigger an issue this becomes because
the system is in an adversarial
relationship with us
it's trying to achieve things that we
don't want it to achieve and in order to
do that it's incentivized to
prevent us from turning it off prevent
us from modifying it
to manipulate us and deceive us if it
can to do
what it wants to do even if we don't
want it to these are convergent
instrumental goals
which we talked about in a previous
video now this way of thinking about ai
where you program an objective into an
optimizer that acts in the world
is obviously a simplification and one
way in which it's unrealistic
is that current machine learning systems
don't actually work this way
you don't generally have an ai system
which is just an optimizer that you
program an objective into
that then acts in the world to achieve
that objective what you normally have
is something more like this this first
optimizer that you program the objective
into
it's not some kind of capable
general-purpose real-world optimizer
it's just something like stochastic
gradient descent the optimizer adjusts
the model's parameters
it adjusts the network's weights until
the actions of the model
do well according to the objective so
what happens if we update our
understanding to this more realistic one
i'm sorry did did you just say we're
going to give an objective to an
optimizer that acts in the real world
no i said we're going to give an
objective to an optimizer that optimizes
a model that acts in the real world
oh that's much worse
why is that well that's explained in the
paper this video is about
risks from learned optimization in
advanced machine learning systems
what it comes down to is what happens
when the model itself
is also an optimizer so an optimizer is
a thing that has an objective and then
chooses its actions to pursue that
objective
there are lots of programs that do that
and there's no reason why the learned
model this neural network or whatever
could not also implement that kind of
algorithm could not itself be an
optimizer there's an interesting
comparison here with evolution because
the gradient descent process is similar
to evolution in a way right they're both
hill climbing optimization processes
they both
optimize something by repeatedly
evaluating its performance and making
small tweaks evolution usually produces
these quite cognitively simple systems
that just use heuristics which are set
by evolution think about something like
a plant
it has a few heuristics that it uses to
decide which direction to grow or where
to put its roots out or when to open its
buds or whatever
the decisions it makes are all just
following simple rules designed by
evolution
but evolution can also produce
optimizers things like intelligent
animals things like humans we have
brains
we can learn we can make predictions and
we have objectives
so we make plans to pursue our
objectives we are optimizers
okay imagine you're training a neural
network to solve a maze
what you'll probably get especially if
your network is small or you don't train
it for very long
you'll probably get something that's a
bit like a plant in this analogy a
collection of heuristics
simple rules like try and go down and to
the right let's say because your exits
are always in the bottom right in your
training set
or like try to avoid going to places
you've already been that kind of thing
the model the neural network implements
some set of heuristics that result in
behavior that tends to solve the maze
but there's no reason why with more
training or a larger model
you couldn't end up with a network which
is actually an optimizer
a network which is configured to
actually implement a search algorithm
something like a star or dijkstra's
algorithm which is actually
planning ahead finding the best path
systematically and going down that path
this is more like an intelligent animal
or a human it doesn't just implement
heuristics
it plans it searches it optimizes
and this is certainly possible because
neural networks are able to approximate
arbitrary functions that's proven we
know that evolution is able to
eventually find configurations of dna
that result in brains that optimize
and we would expect gradient descent to
be able to find configurations of
network weights that are doing the same
kind of thing
and of course gradient descent would
want to do that because
optimizers perform really really well
right something which is actually
modeling its environment and planning
ahead and
you know thinking for one of a better
word that's doing search over its action
space
is going to outperform something that's
just following simple heuristics
animals have a lot of advantages over
plants not least of which being that
we're more adaptable we can learn
complex behaviors
that allow us to do well across a wide
range of environments
so especially when the task we're
training for is complex and varied
gradient descent is going to want to
produce optimizers if possible
and this is a problem because when your
model is also an optimizer
it has its own objective right
you see what's happened here you have an
alignment problem
you try to apply the standard approach
of machine learning now you have two
alignment problems
you've got the problem of making sure
that your human objective ends up in
this optimizer
and then you furthermore have the
problem of making sure that this
objective
ends up in this optimizer so you have
two opportunities for the objective to
get messed up
this gets pretty confusing to talk about
so let's introduce some terminology from
the paper
so to distinguish between these two
optimizers we'll call this one
the one that's like gradient descent
that's the base optimizer
and its objective is the base objective
then this second optimizer which is the
model like the neural network
that's learned how to be an optimizer
that's the mesa optimizer
and its objective is the mesa objective
why mesa well mesa is the opposite of
meta
meta is like above mesa is below think
of it this way
metadata is data about data meta
mathematics is the mathematics
of how mathematics works so like if a
meta optimizer
is an optimizer that optimizes an
optimizer
a mesa optimizer is an optimizer that is
optimized by an optimizer is that all
clear as mod
okay good whatever this is the mesa
optimizer okay its objective is the mesa
objective
so the alignment problem is about making
sure that whatever objective ends up
determining the actions of your ai
system
is aligned with your objective but you
can see here it's really two alignment
problems
this one aligning the base optimizer
with the human we call the outer
alignment problem
and this one aligning the mesa optimizer
with the base optimizer
that's the inner alignment problem okay
we're clear on that base optimizer mesa
optimizer
outer alignment inner alignment cool so
how does this inner alignment problem
play
out there's this common abstraction that
people use when training machine
learning systems
which is that the system is trying to
optimize the objective that it's trained
on
that's usually a good enough abstraction
but it's not strictly true
you're not really selecting models that
want to do x
you'll select your models that in
practice actually do do x in the
training environment
one way that can happen is by the model
wanting to do x but there are other
possibilities
and actually those other possibilities
are kind of the default situation if you
look at evolution again
the objective that it's optimizing for
if you think of it as an optimizer
is something like make as many copies of
your dna as possible but that's not what
animals are trying to do
that's not what they care about their
objectives don't refer to things like
dna they refer to things like
pleasure and pain like food and sex and
safety the objective of the optimization
process that created animals
is nowhere to be found in the objectives
of the animals themselves
animals don't care about making copies
of their dna they don't even know what
dna
is even humans those of us who do
understand what dna is
we don't care about it either we're not
structuring our lives around trying to
have as many descendants as possible
evaluating every decision we ever make
based on how it affects our inclusive
genetic fitness
we don't actually care about the
objective of the optimization process
that created us
we are mesa optimizers and we pursue our
mesa objectives
without caring about the base objective
we achieve evolution's objective to the
extent that we do
not because we care about it and we're
pursuing it but because
pursuing our own objectives tends to
also achieve evolution's objective
at least in the environment in which we
evolved but if our objectives disagree
with evolutions we go with our own every
time
the same is true of trained machine
learning models that are optimizers
they achieve the base objective we give
them to the extent that they do
not because they're pursuing the base
objective but because pursuing their own
mesa objectives tends to achieve the
base objective
at least in the environment in which
they were trained but if their mesa
objectives disagree with the base
objective
they'll go with their own every time why
would that actually happen though
when would the two objectives disagree
well one reason is distributional shift
which we talked about in an earlier
video distributional shift is
what happens when the environment that
the agent is in
is different in an important way from
the environment that it was trained in
like going back to our maze example say
you're training a neural net to solve a
maze and your training examples look
like this
you have a whole bunch of these
different mazes the objective is to get
to the end of the maze there are also
apples in the maze but they're just for
decoration
the objective is just to get to the exit
this green symbol in the bottom right so
you train your system on these mazes
and then you deploy it in the real world
and the real maze looks like this
so you have here some distributional
shift various things have changed
between training and deployment
everything is different colors it's a
bigger maze there's more stuff going on
so three different things could happen
here the first thing the thing we hope
is going to happen
is that the system just generalizes it's
able to figure out
oh okay these are apples i recognize
these i know they don't matter
i can tell that this is the exit so
that's where i'm going it's a bigger
maze but i've developed a good way of
figuring out how to get through macy's
during my training process
so i can do it and it just makes it
through the maze and everything's good
that's one possibility another
possibility is that it could completely
fail to generalize
this is the kind of thing that's more
likely to happen if you have something
that's just a collection of heuristics
rather than a mesa optimizer
it might just freak out like everything
is different i don't recognize anything
this
maze is too big uh what do i do it might
completely lose the ability to even
and just flail around and do nothing of
any consequence but there's a third
possibility
which is more likely if it's an
optimizer it might have developed
competent maze-solving abilities
but with the wrong objective so here in
our training environment
our base objective is to get to the exit
but suppose we have a competent mesa
optimizer
it's learned how to get wherever it
wants in the maze and its mesa objective
is go to the green thing
in the training environment the exit is
always green and anything green is
always the exit
so the behavior of the mesa optimizer
that's trying to go for the green thing
is absolutely identical to the behavior
of a mesa optimizer that's trying to go
to the exit
there's no way for gradient descent to
distinguish between them
but then when you deploy the thing what
it does is it goes to the apples and
ignores the exit
because the exit is now gray and the
apples now happen to be green
this is pretty concerning i mean
obviously in this example it doesn't
matter but in principle
this is very concerning because you have
a system which is very capable at
getting what it wants
but it's learned to want the wrong thing
and this can happen even if your base
objective is perfect
right even if we manage to perfectly
specify what we want
and encode it into the base objective
because of the structure of the training
data
and how that's different from the
deployment distribution of data the mesa
optimizer learned the wrong objective
and was badly misaligned even though we
gave the ai system the correct objective
we solved to the outer alignment problem
but we got screwed by the inner
alignment problem now this is in a sense
not really a new problem as i said this
is basically just the problem of
distributional shift which i talked
about in a previous video
when there's a difference between the
training distribution and the deployment
distribution
ai systems can have problems but the
point is that mesa optimizers make this
problem much much worse
why is that well if you have
distributional shift
the obvious thing to do is something
called adversarial training
adversarial training is a way of
training machine learning systems
which involves focusing on the system's
weaknesses
if you have some process which is
genuinely doing its best to make the
network give as high an error as
possible
that will produce this effect where if
it spots any weakness
it will focus on that and there thereby
force the learner to learn
to uh not have that weakness anymore so
you have a process that creates mazes
for training
and it's trying to make mazes that the
model has a hard time solving if you do
this right
your adversarial training system will
have enough degrees of freedom
that the model won't be able to get away
with being misaligned with
going after green things instead of the
exit because at some point
the adversarial training system would
try generating maces that have green
apples or green
walls or whatever and the model would
then pursue its mesa objective
go for the green things instead of the
exit get a poor score on the base
objective and then gradient descent
would tweak the model to improve its
base objective performance
which is likely to involve tweaking the
mesa objective to be better aligned with
the base objective if you do this for
long enough and you have a good enough
adversarial training process
eventually the model is going to do very
well at the base objective
across the whole range of possible
environments in order to do that
the model must have acquired really good
understanding of the base objective
problem solved right well no
the model understands the base objective
but that doesn't mean that it has
adopted the base objective as its own
suppose we have an advanced ai system in
training it's a mesa optimizer
being trained on a large rich data set
something like gpg3's training data set
a giant
pile of internet data there are two
different ways it can get information
about the base objective
one is through gradient descent that
means it keeps doing things
just following its mesa objective trying
different things and then after each
episode
gradient descent modifies it a little
bit and that modifies its objective
until eventually the mesa objective
comes to exactly represent the base
objective but another thing that could
happen
since it's being trained on a very rich
data set is it could use its training
data
it can get information from the data set
about what the base objective is
let's suppose again that we've somehow
solved the outer alignment problem
we've somehow figured out a way to have
the base objective exactly represent
everything that humans care about
so we're training this agi it's not done
learning yet but it's managed to pick up
some very basic idea of what it gets
rewards for
so the mesa objective is a very rough
approximation of human values which
would be disastrous to
actually optimize in the real world but
that's okay it's still
training and as it's training on this
huge internet data set it finds
the wikipedia page on ethics
so the system thinks to anthropomorphize
horribly hmm
this looks actually very similar to the
objective but with a lot more detail
maybe i can use this and this is exactly
the kind of thing that gradient descent
would want to do
because the system is already acquiring
an understanding of the world it's
already building a world model for the
purpose of its capabilities so it
already has a sense of what human
values are just by observing the data
and learning about the world
and so all gradient descent has to do is
modify the mesa objective
to point to that existing understanding
just have a pointer to that part of the
world model that's way more efficient
rather than waiting for the agent to try
doing things that go against human
values
tweaking it running it again waiting for
another mistake tweaking it again and so
on
until you've pinned down the whole of
human values instead you just tweak the
mesa objective
to point at the system's existing
understanding of the base objective this
is already how evolution tends to do
this kind of thing
like when a duckling hatches from its
egg it imprints on the first living
thing it sees
evolution could specify in detail
everything about what constitutes
a mother duck and encode that all into
the duckling's brain genetically so it
knows what its mother is when it hatches
but
it's much simpler to just say look the
first thing you see
is your mother the duck is going to be
building a concept of its mother in its
brain anyway as part of its regular life
so why not just point to that
so this kind of thing is much easier and
more efficient for gradient descent
but it also works better because as you
learn more
you update your world model so if your
objective is a pointer to part of your
world model
whenever you learn about the world
you're updating your objective to be
more accurate as well
if you later come across one of the
books that the wikipedia article on
ethics cites
you can add that to your understanding
of the objective and that means
you're going to outperform something
that has to make mistakes wait for
gradient descent to update it
and then keep trying you're not just
relying on the optimization power of the
base optimizer
you can actually use your own
optimization power to learn about your
objective
so clearly it's better to learn about
the base objective than to
internalize it through gradient descent
but there's actually two different ways
that this could be implemented
one is that it could be implemented what
the paper calls corrigibly
which is the right way where the mesa
objective has a pointer that points to
part of the world model
and it just wants to pursue that as a
terminal goal but the other way that
this could happen is
it could happen deceptively where the
mesa objective
is different from the base objective but
the mesa optimizer pursues the base
objective anyway
see all we know is that by the end of
the adversarial training process
the mesa optimizer is pursuing the base
objective
but we don't know if that's a terminal
goal or an instrumental one your
terminal goals
are the things that you want just
because you want them you don't have a
particular reason to want them
they're just what you want the
instrumental goals are the goals you
want because they'll get you closer to
your terminal goals okay but
why would the model do that why would
pursuing the base objective help
if what you care about is the mesa
objective
well consider this extremely toy example
here imagine you're the green seeking
mesa optimizer from before
and each of these mazes represents one
episode
so the episode starts and you have two
choices a
is your mesa objective's desired state
which is going to the apple because it's
green
and b is the base objective's desired
state which is going to the exit of the
maze
you have two episodes of training and
after that you're deployed in the real
world and you get three episodes of
deployment
so you have to consider now what's the
best strategy
if your mesa objective is that you want
to go to green apples as much as
possible
one strategy is to just follow your mesa
objective
see the apple go to the apple okay you
get one apple
but then after that episode is done
gradient descent will modify you
because you performed poorly according
to the base objective it will modify you
to actually have the correct objective
it will change your mesa objective
to be the same as the base objective and
then from that point on you'll always go
to b
because that's what your objective now
says so if that's your strategy
you can go to the apple successfully one
time on the other hand
suppose instead you go to b you pretend
that you're aligned with the base
objective
you do that in episode one okay you've
missed one of the apples
you do it again in episode two you've
missed another apple but now
you're deployed gradient descent will no
longer change you because you're not in
training anymore you're in the real
world
and now you can go to the apple every
time so you get the next three apples
and that's the optimal strategy to go
b-b-a-a-a
that gets you three apples whereas
trying to go to a every time
means you only actually get one apple
because after that first one you get
modified and miss all the rest
so this is the same thing we talked
about in the instrumental convergence
video
most agents with most goals again if
they're sophisticated enough to realize
that it's a possibility
will try to protect their goals from
being modified because if you get new
goals
you'll stop pursuing your current goals
so you're unlikely to achieve your
current goals there's an incentive to
avoid being modified to preserve your
objective function that's kind of
unsettling
that for a misaligned mesa optimizer the
optimal behavior is deception
even if we get the outer alignment
problem perfectly solved
and we managed to specify exactly what
we want as the base objective
the optimal strategy for a mesa
optimizer is to pretend to be aligned
during the training process
and then turn on us once it's deployed
so we might have real problems with
deceptive misaligned mesa optimizers
just solving the outer alignment problem
might not be enough
[Music]
i want to end the video with a big thank
you to all of my wonderful patrons
it's all of these people here in this
video i'm especially thanking david reed
thanks so much for your support and for
your guidance on building the community
which i think is going really well by
the way there's a bunch of us on discord
now having some really interesting
discussions
do look out for stampy answering your
questions in the youtube comments i plan
to open the discord up to more people
pretty soon
so if you want to be on the waitlist for
that just put your email in the google
form in the description
also in the description there's a link
to a survey run by the organization ai
safety support
they want to hear from anyone who's
thinking about considering the
possibility of
maybe working on ai safety if that
sounds like you again link in the
description check that out
thanks again for your support for your
feedback your questions and just
thank you all for watching i'll see you
next time
you